hace un año recibimos una llamada que
cambiaría nuestras vidas por completo
nos dijeron que ya no íbamos a poder dar
shows o sea ya no podíamos trabajar el
negocio se había terminado junto con
nuestros sueños y 25 años de carrera nos
dijeron que el fracaso era inevitable y
como no pensarlo si estamos en el
negocio del entretenimiento somos magos
si se abre un panorama complicado pero
algo bueno de ser magos es que creemos
en la magia y la magia es la capacidad
de desaparecer las limitaciones mentales
para permitirnos que sucedan cosas que
creemos o creíamos imposibles era
momento de aplicar los conceptos de la
magia a nuestras vidas con la diferencia
de que el acto que tenemos que hacer en
esta ocasión era desaparecer el miedo al
cambio un truco nada fácil lo irónico es
que la magia no sucede por arte de magia
sucede a través del trabajo la práctica
la prueba y el error el esfuerzo y la
dedicación hoy hemos evolucionado a un
show de magia interactivo que gracias a
la tecnología rompe fronteras y es
posible presentarlo en diferentes partes
del mundo
al mismo tiempo justo desde este mismo
foro
es el poder de la evolución lo que está
cambiando hoy en día es la forma de
hacer las cosas la tecnología está
avanzando cada vez más rápido y tenemos
que aprovechar las ventajas que nos está
dando darwin decía que no es la especie
más fuerte ni la más inteligente en la
que sobrevive es la que mejor se adapta
a los cambios empezando por nuestra
mente porque aquí es donde comienzan los
cambios sin duda alguna la magia más
poderosa de todas es la que sucede aquí
adentro y para lo que sigue lo único que
necesitamos es tu atención
en estas tarjetas que no siempre es
algunas palabras que definen algo de lo
que estamos viviendo en estos momentos
tenemos palabras como cambio amor
libertad tiempo entre muchas otras vamos
a revolver las mientras las revolvemos
necesitamos que veas de qué color vienes
vestida o vestido bien ahora piensa en
la primera letra de ese color por
ejemplo si estás vestida o vestido de
color negro la primera letra sería n ya
ubicas de tu letra bien con mucha
atención
y esto
si la primera letra de tu color forma
parte de alguna de estas palabras
recuerda esa palabra por ejemplo
por ejemplo si el color que pensaste es
negro la primera letra es n
forma parte de la palabra unión así que
vas a recordar la palabra unión punto
importante si la letra del color que
pensaste está en más de una tarjeta solo
recuerda una tarjeta no tienes que
recordar todas listos
empezamos unión
libertad
trabajo
disfrutar
tiempo
diálogo
luchar
valor
[Música]
bien ahora tienes una nueva palabra en
mente piensa en la primera letra de esa
nueva palabra y utilizando esa nueva
letra vas a hacer lo mismo con estas
palabras si tu nueva letra se encuentra
dentro de una de estas palabras recuerda
esta palabra vas
cambio
voluntad
hoy
casa
compromiso
[Música]
paciencia
amor
ahora tienes una nueva palabra por favor
piensa en ella
la palabra que estás pensando en este
momento es indispensable para adaptarnos
a los cambios la palabra que estás
pensando es
voluntad porque la voluntad es lo que
necesitamos para llevar nuestros
pensamientos a la acción así es yo la
voluntad hace que la magia suceda y
hablando de magia les vamos a revelar
tres secretos que hemos utilizado para
evolucionar ante la adversidad el primer
secreto es flexibilidad cognitiva ésta
es la capacidad para adaptar nuestro
pensamiento ante conceptos y situaciones
cambiantes novedosas e inesperadas como
por ejemplo esta caja de madera que en
realidad no es de madera no es de cartón
pero la formamos para que parezca que es
de madera y ahora que lo sabes tener
flexibilidad te ayuda a aceptar el
cambio lo que nos lleva al segundo
secreto y este es explotar la
creatividad para poder ir más allá de lo
que creemos tenemos que salir de nuestra
zona de confort y atrevernos a hacer
cosas nuevas muchas veces no sabemos en
lo que somos capaces hasta que lo
intentamos y decimos intentamos porque
la creatividad requiere colaboración por
cierto es importante que vean que la
caja está completamente vacía
ahora me tocó la parte fácil que es la
tapa sí pero el destino es lo importante
recuerda el estilo
por favor
por todos lados que no hay nada
ahora vamos a armarla y este es un
ejemplo de trabajo en equipo es otro que
me sí claro por supuesto esta charla
está llena de ejemplos
no hay nada excelente y es de suma
importancia que esté a la vista de los
espectadores en todo momento así que
aquí la vamos a dejar es más si están
viendo esta charla con alguien más
elijan a uno para que cuide la caja tú
el elegido no pongas atención a la
charla sólo cuida la caja tienes un
trabajo muy importante recuerda la caja
o la caja o querés importantes y el
tercer secreto es actitud positiva esta
es necesaria para transformar las ideas
en acciones bien no dijo winston
churchill el éxito es ir de fracaso en
fracaso sin perder el entusiasmo una
persona con una actitud positiva es
aquella que no se limita a su rutina
diaria en la que siempre da un extra la
que ama lo que hace y la que a través de
pequeñas acciones hace una diferencia en
su día y en el día de quienes la rodea y
teniendo todo esto en mente
así es como la magia sucede
porque lo único imposible es aquello que
no intentas así es estamos llegando al
final de esta charla y no nos queremos
ir sin dejar un mensaje claro el gran
truco es creer en ti mismo no dejes de
esforzarte para desarrollar tu
flexibilidad explotar tu creatividad y
siempre tener actitud positiva siéntete
orgulloso de lo que has logrado atrévete
a ser mejor sorprendente a ti mismo
porque esto es lo que te da fuerza
confianza y valor porque la más interna
no necesita público ocurre en el día a
día en tus acciones en el ser parte de
algo que mueve al mundo la magia ocurre
rompiendo imposibles ocurre al creer y
al hacerlo vas a convertir lo ordinario
en extraordinario porque la magia está
en ti gracias muchas gracias mi nombre
es young y yo soy muy
[Música]